what is it like finding the balance
between modern action but also designing
for the 80s 90s classic action movies
that the series is trying to channel
that's a great question um yeah I guess
it's it's really based on the characters
too and the story how we designed the
action um I think that's our our
blueprint or you know our outline and
then we start to put the questions out
to the creators like what about this
what about this and they're like ah and
then they start to expound on it and we
create a sequence that nobody would have
come up on their own but we've
collaborated to create something unique
and special and I think this show
highlighted that a lot with our
sequences so I know they're guys who
like to take big swings especially with
the series and not hold back was there
any idea in that respect that you pitch
to them you thought they were going to
say no that's too much but it's now in
the final version of the show no I mean
everything they threw I know that I knew
the elevator sequence was going to be a
difficult one and timec consuming and I
you know with with production everyone's
in full swing so it's hard to get
everyone's undivided
attention and especially because the set
had to be built out and it's smaller
than a real Elevator Shaft and that
creates safety issues on my side so a
lot of testing happened in fact um our
co-coordinator Josh Kimble was left back
in Albuquerque to test the sequence
while we C while I came here to scout
the sequences that needed to be shot
here in Vegas from the car chase to you
know um mainly the car chase like how
are we going to pull this off but
there's a lot of little pieces connected
pieces that needed to tie in with the
stuff we shot in Albuquerque all the
hard work that went into that elevator
sequence spot on so what a good build
right there all right so Kevin I was
doing a little IMDb stalking and I
noticed a lot of your credits are you
know maybe a little more grounded and
serious film so what was it like
bringing to bringing some authenticity
to a series that leans a little more you
know absurd comedy um it was great it
was it was a great opportunity for me um
and I I like to think I have a
relatively good sense of humor um but
says who yeah right I think um it
actually this the the the script and
everything that's what kind of brought
me in you know coming off of a show like
Jack Ryan um very serious stuff going on
and then I I read the first four
episodes of this this and I'm just bust
in a gut laughing and going okay I
definitely want to be part of this show
it's it's uh it's a it's it's going to
be a good opportunity good a good good
time to uh be on a good crew you know
and not take not take things too serious
you know love I pitched the question
that way and the first thing I thought
it was like yeah Fast and Furious movies
those are really grounded and serious
right yeah right I love those movies so
much Marcus for you what do you find
more challenging doing stunt
coordination for an actor playing a
character who's actually an expert and
knows what they're doing or for an actor
playing a character who is undertrained
and or drunker High Hey cuz then they
think they know it that's fair and then
they won't be able to adapt and change
and it might be something just with
camera you know like a directorial thing
like hey you need to turn this way well
I wouldn't be that in the real situation
so they're they think they know more
than they actually know and that limits
them as far as making them look
actually better than what they should be
doing you know what they are so okay can
you break down any specific styles that
you pinpointed for I guess in particular
Ava mcnight Gomez and trunk just to
differentiate their fighting styles in a
way that maybe reflects who they are and
their past training okay let's just go
with let's start with um Nick's
character mcnight um I
think he's you know he's the heart and
soul of the team but
he's
also he's the the guy that doesn't he's
the Energizer he takes a look and he
keeps on ticking you know which makes
him like Brad Pit in Fight Club he's
always getting smashed ah hit me
again so you know like I think Nick
created his own
character whether it's kind of based off
of that or not
but for the series you know that
actually is a is a real jucks the
Precision with the other people like
trunk which is you know brutal and just
you know picking guys up and slamming
guys and um with the girls we try to
create you know um with
um and her character is this Russian spy
but she can't give it away that she is
and and then when her when her and
Shelly go at it at the end you know like
I just want to make that a fun chick
fight you you know on the top of a hotel
great success with that yet another one
that just stands out big time we had a
lot of limitations with that fight too
literally every single thing you pull
off in this show seems like there's a
million production limitations that I
don't know how you overcome but that's
why you work with guys like that they
know what they're doing and it's and
it's a good crew I mean it's it's a crew
that learns to work together and tick
well together and where One Drops
something the other one the rest of them
pick it up and we we keep running with
that ball like rugby makes all the
difference and I I really do believe you
kind of feel that radiating off the
screen in the finished product and
quality of it all right Kevin what is
something that happens in this show that
might make someone else out there think
like there's no way that that's
realistic it can't happen that way but
it's actually really authentic to how a
mission like this might unfold um Bas uh
I mean realistically it's it's like
Murphy's Law I mean
for for us anytime we're going down
range doing something like you always
have to plan for Murphy's Law like man
if if ever there's going to be something
that's going to be screwed up and go
wrong or if it can go wrong it's going
to go wrong so um in you know many many
many scenarios there you have to plan
for that for the for these weird things
that that pop up you know the freaking
Hilo crashes you know it's like
ridiculous and they just and the writing
was was phenomenal you know it just like
one one Ranch after another being thrown
in into this script you know and I think
it's awesome you know and and it kind of
piggyback what what Marcus was saying
about the about the cast and the crew
and everybody you know I think it was a
testament to things would get dropped
and and it it's great because I think
the storyline everybody was everybody
was Allin invested into this show and
they're sitting there looking at it
going oh my God I can't wait to see what
happens next so it's like you know
everybody
fought hard to make make things work and
you know come together as a crew in the
end it was it was phenomenal experience
all right I'll end with this one to
highlight the cast a little so let's say
you as in real you you are called upon
to find a bomb in Las Vegas you could
pick two actors from this Ensemble to be
on your elite special forces team which
two actors do you choose and why the
actor not their
characters you can start oh
um I would pick Nick for sure is
you know Nick's Nick's I'm I'm excited
to see where Nick's career is going to
go um he's you know I've worked with
I've worked with Pratt and Wahlberg and
krinski dudes like that that are that
are major action stars and I I see Nick
and that that same trajectory and uh I
don't know who else I would
pick maybe Gomez just
because I mean always GNA need a sniper
you know I think yeah I'm going to go
with those twoo good team there yeah
hm I'm going to go
with I'm gonna go with Eugene curveball
I like it Eugene
and uh Anastasia I'm not going to go to
the J I'm GNA go the complete opposite
nice like it Eugene's cuz he's a father
you know and he's he's fighting for his
daughter you know he's doing everything
for her to save the you know save the
world but or save
Vegas but really to save his daughter so
I and he's he's the straight lace guy
that gets high and has to figure it out
you know um Anastasia CU
she's you know she's that chameleon that
blends in and switches for her needs and
um yeah those are the dangerous ones you
know the father and the chameleon I like
it I like it I wasn't ready for that
take it that another plot Shi season two
you alongside the two of them I'll watch
it